let's go to the 7-1 for area code caller
from seven one four who's there hey um
it's Laura from Los Angeles hey Laura
what's going on hey I was wondering if
you had an opinion on BD Atlantic
article about Bryan Singer that came out
basically that he has been allegedly
abusing boys for 20-something years in
Hollywood and somehow the me2 movement
hasn't really effectively shut him down
so I was wondering if you follow that or
if you have any opinions on that I
didn't see that article is that is that
new yeah like it really just came out
within the past week okay and so the
claim is that so we're talking about
Bryan Singer we're talking about the
director writer here rector x-men and
Bohemian Rhapsody got it and the claim
is that he was sexually abusing men
males under age 18 yeah young boys like
they're saying he has been doing this
for a while and he's been getting away
with it and so some of the accusers have
come out and they're saying one of the
young actors Brad Renfro who passed away
from I think drug addiction that he was
actually one of the victims and that's
what led to his drug addiction Wow well
listen I'm taking your word that this is
what the article says but I really don't
know anything about it all I can say is
what I say at the beginning of all of
these Fiasco's which is if there are
people claiming that they were
victimized by an individual particularly
when they are they are numerous we have
to take that seriously it needs to be
investigated and it should have
consequences if indeed if indeed it's
true but I've just not seen that
particular article now let me ask you
this Laura does the article make a case
for why he hasn't suffered consequences
um they're saying he kind of deflected
by saying it's homophobia so it's the
oldest trick in the book to say okay
he's a powerful gay producer-director oh
he must be abusing boys right but that
would explain why there are specific
accusers right what do you mean in other
words that might be something you can
say if the allegations
just sort of general like this guy's a
pedophile type of thing but if specific
users have come forward then that
doesn't seem like a good defense yeah I
guess it's just he's so powerful and
maybe the me2 movement prioritize
stories about women and so the males who
said that they were abused were not
prioritized quite as much I understand
yeah that I have actually that element
I've heard and read before and that
wouldn't be new I'll check into it Laura
what's the weather like in LA I is it
great
well it's overcast right now oh what a
tragedy unbelievable yeah you're telling
me it's cloudy and 65 yeah that's
exactly what it is right now Wow well
listen I feel really really sorry for
you and hopefully tomorrow the weather
is better thank you I appreciate that
all right appreciate the call thanks so
much for calling in